hey guys Pete here this is going to be a
continuation of my mr. robot season one
rewatch this is my recap and review for
season 1 episode 4 another good episode
right on the back end of episode 3 and I
will be continuing going through the
rest of the season on the lead up to the
season 3 premiere next week so the title
of this episode is Damon's which is a
pretty interesting concept and we'll get
to that later but the word Damon's is
very similar to the word demon's and we
see Elliot in front one of his most
pressing demons with his morphine
addiction after he turned in Fernando
Vera who was shayla's employer and
connection for the drugs that he needs
in this episode we see Elliott start to
go through withdrawal we see that it
affects everything in his life it seems
like he has some experience with it like
he knows what's going to happen but he's
presented with this situation where they
have to act fast in order to destroy the
tape backups at steel mountain before he
has time to detox properly this of
course leads to some problems and we'll
talk about all of that as we go along
here so I guess one of the things we
learn about here more than we have in
the past is about the other members of F
society not concrete details but we do
get a lot more scenes with them and as
viewers we get a chance to profile them
and realize why each person has their
strengths that brought them to being in
the room at the Coney Island arcade of
course these aren't random people these
are people that were brought together
for a reason and we get that idea here
that they all have their skills they all
have their personal quirks or whatever
you want to call that and it's a pretty
good episode to build that part of the
season up Romero is in some ways the
antithesis of Elliott in this episode
because he knows what Elliott's going he
knows what's going on with Elliott he
knows that he's going through withdrawal
where the others may not have noticed he
has a couple really good lines in this
up
sewed and one of them is there's a
casualty in every revolution so we see
that Eliot is walking that line of
whether he's going to get through this
make this happen or if he's going to
disappear into himself and everything
would end of course since it's an
episodic television show we pretty much
know he's gonna get through it one way
or the other but it is an interesting
situation because up to this point we've
pretty much seen him being able to
handle anything he actually says at one
point I know I broke my own rule it
needs me just as much as I need it the
moment was destined every choice
bringing me closer to this one line this
last line I promise and he's referring
to us here his imaginary friend and we
can feel for him in this situation but
he is definitely a different kind of
character when his backs against the
wall
as mentioned Romero knows what's
happening he doesn't really trust Eliot
he says so too
Mobley at one point when they're
stealing the car but at the same time
they don't really want to blow up steel
Mountain so they end up going along with
him because it seems like he's pretty
much the ringleader here we've been
introduced into this situation with him
coming on after the fact but it starts
to come out more clearly here that he's
more important and mr. robot says that
directly again he emphasizes that
Eliot's the only force of nature at play
here which is very telling about the
composition of everything that we're
seeing as it relates to the evil Corp
hack so they have an argument about this
new plan that Eliot has but they don't
really have any other way around it
because of the fact that they find out
because they still have access to evil
corpse computers that the backup files
will soon be spread out into five
locations and basically breaking into
one location will be a lot easier than
traveling around the country and doing
it five times Elliot seems pretty
confident in his idea that the people
there are the security flaw in a place
that's meant
not have any and he eventually gets
everyone to go around with him we see
him do his very last line as I talked
about earlier we see that paranoia kicks
in almost immediately afterwards there's
a shot where he yells at some strangers
on the street
Darlene knocks on his door and he has
that feeling that it's the cops coming
in to bust him but as far as we can tell
his plan to put that raspberry pie into
steel Mountain is a solid one the others
have small disagreements with the idea
but they all seem to think it'll work if
they can pull it off this means they
have to go into the physical location in
the Adirondack Mountains in upstate New
York Darlene and Trenton stay behind
there at Coney Island so that they can
communicate back and forth and Darlene
is tasked with making contact with the
dark army through her contacts and
setting things up so that they can
destroy the Chinese back up at the same
time if they can't do both it's not
worth doing so they do go Elliot gets
sick almost immediately in the car from
what we've seen Elliot hasn't done that
much you know as viewers of the show we
haven't seen him do anything other than
leave that server infected there is some
hints that Elliot may be doing more than
what we've actually seen on-screen but
either way they do go north as he's in
the car he starts to really hit the bad
point of his withdrawal and he talks
about these ideas of Damon's those are
programs that are within an operating
system that perform tasks that don't
require anything from like they don't
you don't have to do anything to make
them do what they do they don't require
interaction or you to type in commands
from the keyboard they're just always in
the background doing their things he
says they're always monitoring logging
so on and so forth like a program
running in the background silently while
we're busy doing other [ __ ] they're
always they're always active he says
this is an interesting term and an
interesting process that has a very nice
parallel with our own human bodies and
how they operate so this is pretty
writing I think here and I like the fact
that demons and demons are basically the
same thing in humanity you know what I
mean like whenever things were going
wrong with someone they were thought to
be possessed by demons when actually we
know a lot more in today's world about
mental health and different seeing so
pretty interesting I like this a part of
it
for sure another thing Elliott says is
intentions are irrelevant they don't
drive us demons do and me I've got more
than most so this makes us really kind
of wonder about where Elliott thinks his
demons exist and when I mean at least
for me as I mentioned in my season one
episode one recap we know that he was
sent to see Christa but we don't know
why we know that he has mental health
issues but we don't know what extent
they've affected his life the biggest
thing we actually know is that the death
of his father is a huge tragedy a huge
trauma that he experienced as a child at
around eight years old and that is the
only fleshed out even though it's not
fleshed out that much that's really the
only fleshed out driving motivation
other than his obvious contempt for
modern society so Elliott throws up in
the backseat they have to make a stop
Romero kind of explains what's going to
happen he's not seeming all that helpful
but he's absolutely right
Elliott adds in another symptom which is
hyper sensitivity to light and he drops
one more of his little Elliott nuggets
there where he tells us don't be mad at
me that I slipped I'm about to change
the world so he has justification for
everything that's going down I would
mention that the lines are a little bit
more blurred here about what's real and
what isn't real I mean obviously be
launched into this giant dream sequence
which has been fairly important
throughout and is still theorized on to
what it actually means but with this
talk of demons you know you have to
really think about what are his
processes that are running that are
keeping him from telling us what's
actually going on or for him to actually
understand
and what is actually going on I mean
does that make sense I'm not sure he
says at one point my subconscious
running in the background making me
doubt what I got everyone else to
believe so he's having second thoughts
but at this point he's sick and he's but
at this point he's sick and throwing up
and full-on the chills and whatever else
is going on with him so the plan is in
action because there's no time left
there's a definite connection here with
the bugs that he mentioned in the last
episode and the daemon so we'll see how
that plays out as mentioned this dream
sequence turns out to be pretty
important as far as bringing up this
idea of monsters so we have demons and
we have monsters and we have a key that
continues to pop up in this dream as it
carries on we do see in the F Society
announcement or video that plays during
this sequence F Society promises to
exorcise demons Elliott is obviously
thinking about the loss of his father we
see him arrive at his childhood home
there's a 404 message which is an error
message in the lot of his childhood home
there we see his mom force him to eat a
bite of QWERTY who was you know his only
friend that he tells Angela we also see
Angela eating the fish and she says it's
delicious he finds the key at one point
in pops famous raspberry pie which is an
obvious reference to the raspberry pie
that he was going to install in steel
mountain and I don't know if there's a
great explanation of exactly what
happens in this but the mystery that it
creates is very good I really enjoyed
this part some of the other stuff that I
like less about this series I think
things like this make up for it and we
have more of this to come in the future
and I think what stood out to me most
about this dream sequence on this watch
and this is something that people have
talked about certainly but what stood
out to me on this watch this time was
that Angela mentions that he's only been
born a month ago like we see her say yes
yes I will like they're going to get
married when he finds the key in the
raspberry pie but when they get back
into when they're alone
the arcade she says I just told those
people what they wanted to hear and it
does seem and this is not a spoiler this
hasn't been this isn't something that
has come up later that I'm referring to
but it makes it seem like Angela may
have more of a part to play in
situations as well
she lost a parent just as he did and
although she seems to be like on the
outside orbit of things it's very
interesting that you know his oldest
friend the one there that he met as a
child that she has this other side in
this visions like she says I just told
them what they wanted to hear you're not
going to do it are you change the world
figures the only born a month ago you're
afraid afraid of your monster and she
says do you even know what it is so that
seems a lot more like foreshadowing at
this time than I ever did in the past
and it kind of gets me pretty hyped up
about season 3 because s Mel's been
saying that Angela's role is going to
become a lot more clear so there is also
a little bit of a tie back there to when
she's talking to Shayla what Shayla is
pretty awesome in this episode we have
to acknowledge that for sure her and
Angela hang out and she sort of has this
like calming effect on everyone all the
time so we can see how she's pretty good
for Elliot she helps Angela by giving
her some drugs I guess you could say and
Angela decides that she's going to go
and put the CD into the computer we see
her do that and now we know the dark
army has infiltrated all say so that's
pretty much everything that happens in
the episode I really like how it started
out with him saying I chose this I chose
all of this I would say his idea about
attacking steel mountain sounds
plausible for a inexperienced not
knowing anything kind of computer user
that has no hacking background I think
that you know it makes sense it's good
in that way that we can understand what
he's trying to do he's trying to raise
the temperature to melt some tapes and
this idea that people are the security
flaw and we hear Romero and we hear
Romero mention social engineering which
is something that as people who don't
hack things
kind of figure that that's a big part of
how people do what they do we got a
little bit of dark army here but nothing
conclusive other than the fact that
Cisco is the man that's that both the
contact for Darlene but also the man who
proposed to her who she broke up with
she was telling Ellie about it earlier
that she just needs to stay away from
him for a while and then things will go
back to normal is that Romero had some
really funny lines they were kind of
making fun of the movie hackers when
they were watching it on TV which is
pretty good and you know the meeting
them meeting learning more about the eff
society guys it makes you wonder if
we're gonna learn more about them
particularly Darlene when you're first
watching it seems to me that it gets to
you know you start to notice that she's
more of a main character than the other
members might be so even now I still
wonder what we're gonna learn more about
Darlene and how she ended up at the
arcade so she stays a mystery for the
most part and it was a great I mean I
think it was a great episode I like the
mystery of the hallucination or the
dream that he had when he was doing is
withdrawal we can see that the plan is
going into action at this point so
that's moving along we didn't have big
jumps in the story necessarily but we
did learn a lot and I am interested to
hear what you guys think about it let me
know in the comments please like this
video if you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my channel if you haven't already
make sure you turn on notifications
after that so that you can see my new
videos when they come out we only have a
week left at this point basically until
season 3 starts so I'll be doing plenty
of season 3 videos once that kicks off
check out my patreon if you have a
chance I could really use your support I
really enjoy mr. robot but it's not the
most popular series in the world like
some of the other big TV shows so any
and all support will help to keep these
videos coming thanks for watching guys
I'll talk to you soon